-The president is now telling
government officials
to ignore the law
when it comes to immigration.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Trump is once again freaking out
about the border.
Last week he went to California
to tour a section
of the border wall he claims
his administration has built.
But in reality,
plans for that wall
date back to
the Obama administration.
All Trump did was renovate it.
And he's mad that people
keep pointing that out.
So today he tried a new argument
to convince people
that he is definitely building
his own, brand-new border wall.
-We've built a lot of wall.
A lot of wall.
And it's new wall.
You know, when we rip down
an old wall and then replace it,
it's called a new wall.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, is that what it's called?
Thanks a lot, Bob Vila.
[ Laughter ]
Trump isn't the president.
He's like a wannabe
Property Brother.
He's a Property Stepbrother.
[ Laughter ]
Trump, of course,
bypassed Congress and declared
a national emergency
to build this wall,
and he did so after
the Republican Party
and right-wing pundits spent
years lecturing the rest of us
about the sanctity
of the Constitution.
In fact, Trump himself made
a big show during the campaign
of saying how much he personally
loved the Constitution.
-I feel very strongly
about our Constitution.
I'm proud of it. I love it.
And I want to go through
the Constitution.
That's what we want to do.
I mean, we want to bring
the Constitution back.
-What do you mean,
bring it back?
It didn't go anywhere.
Someone must have switched
his Fox News to HBO
and now he thinks Nick Cage
actually stole the Constitution.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
I saw it on the news.
It was on the news
and let me tell you,
he's not going to be easy
to find
because he has
John Travolta's face.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump, Republicans, and Fox News
spent years telling their
audience that President Obama
was a dictator
trampling on the Constitution,
and yet all of those same people
are now vocally supporting
a president who's been going
around and saying
he wants to get rid of judges
in courts
and complaining that migrants
who exercise their legal right
to seek asylum
get to talk to a lawyer.
-We have to do something
about asylum,
and to be honest with you,
we have to get rid of judges.
They have to get rid of
the whole asylum system
because it doesn't work.
Frankly,
we should get rid of judges.
We have a stupid system
of courts.
It's the craziest thing
in the world.
Our laws are so corrupt
and so stupid.
I call them the dumbest
immigration laws
anywhere on Earth.
If a person puts their foot
over the line,
we have to take them
into our country.
We have to register them.
We then have to ask them
a couple of questions.
Lawyers are telling them
what to say.
They read a little page
given by lawyers
that are all over the place.
You know lawyers.
They tell them what to say.
-Of course it makes sense
that Trump hates lawyers
since this guy is his lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at him.
It's not good.
It's not good when your lawyer
always looks surprised.
I mean, Rudy constantly looks
like he just found out
he's representing Donald Trump.
[ As Giuliani ]That guy?!
Oh, but he's so guilty.
Oh, no, Rudy.
Oh, you stepped in it this time.
[ Laughter ]
Trump wants to get rid of judges
and lawyers and courts.
He doesn't care
what the Constitution says.
In fact, last week
he admitted as much
during a roundtable
with border agents.
First, Trump started out
with a bizarre rant
where he praised their
appearance and also told them
how lucky they are that they
aren't in his position.
-I want to thank my men
and women
who do a tremendous job here
every day.
Very, very proud of their
commitment even though
they're facing extreme
challenges, as you've heard.
-Is there central casting?
I've never seen a group
of people like this.
Everyone's in perfect shape.
And you're proud of what you do?
You wouldn't trade places
with me for anything.
I know that, right?
You're smart.
Don't do it. Don't do it.
-I'm sorry, you want them
to feel bad for you?
You're a billionaire celebrity
who spent most of his life
dating models
and living a gold tower
despite the fact that you can
barely string
three coherent words together.
You misspelled the word
"country,"
and you couldn't pronounce
the word "origins."
You shouldn't be the president
of the country.
You should be on the street
selling...
-Oranges.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But it's what Trump said
to those same border agents
behind the scenes,
without the cameras there,
that's troubling.
According to CNN,
the president told border agents
to not let migrants in.
Tell them we don't have
the capacity, he said.
If judges give you trouble,
say, sorry, judge,
I can't do it,
we don't have the room.
So Trump told border officials
to just ignore the law.
And that's because he's
following the advice
of immigration hard-liners
in his administration
like his creepiest aide,
White House senior policy
advisor, Stephen Miller.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-[ Maniacal laugh ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-"The Wall Street Journal"
reported that Trump
recently told Miller,
one of his most hard-line
advisors
of the administration's
immigration policy,
"You're in charge."
It's especially scary
that a president
who is publicly calling
for judges and courts
to be eliminated is being
advised by the guy
who says this about
the president's power
to change immigration laws.
-Our opponents, the media,
and the whole world
will soon see,
as we begin to take
further actions,
that the powers of the president
to protect our country
are very substantial
and will not be questioned.
-Ugh, he's such a worm.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you act like
you're Darth Vader,
but you sound like
the snotty little Vice President
of the AV club.
[ Nasally ] "The president
can choose whatever projector
he wants to show
whatever movie he wants,
and he will not be questioned!"
Miller isn't the only
creepy weirdo
whispering in Trump's ear.
There's also Fox Business host,
Lou Dobbs,
one of Trump's closest
outside advisers.
Dobbs has spread a bunch
of racist conspiracy theories
on his show, and on top of that,
he can't even pronounce
the names of the cities
he's talking about,
as we discovered last year
during this clip from
a segment on immigration.
Again, this is the guy
advising the president
of the United States
on immigration policy.
-The caravan of mostly
Central American immigrants
is now in the Mexican City
of [mumbles] tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-I...I can't wait.
I can't wait for Trump's next
meeting with border officials.
[ As Trump ] I don't care
what the judges say.
Tell the migrants they have
to go back to [mumbles]
[ Normal voice ] Sorry, where?
[ As Trump ] [Mumbles]
I heard it on "Lou Dobbs."
It's a place. [Mumbles]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Dobbs
is one of Trump's closest
outside advisers on immigration.
In fact, Trump values Dobbs
so much as a confidant
and adviser that he's even
had the TV host
patched in on speakerphone
during high-level
oval office meetings.
Think about that -- you're the
president of the United States.
You can seek advice of anyone
in the world --
scholars, historians,
scientists, lawyers.
And instead, you decide
to take your cues from a guy
who looks like one
of those clowns
you shoot water into
at a carnival.
Seriously, why is everyone
around Trump so creepy?
Look at these guys.
They look like the same guy
at three different stages
of an exorcism.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they look like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They look like
they have different jobs
in the same graveyard.
There's the grave digger,
the corpse he's burying,
and the ghost who's been
watching the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans spent years
lecturing the rest of us
about the Constitution.
It was all a lie.
Trump's telling
government officials
to ignore immigration laws,
but now he's encountering
resistance from the courts
and a Democratic Congress.
In other words,
he keeps hitting...
-A new wall.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪